des hôpitaux des municipalités et des
grandes organisations comme la stm ont
récemment été prise en otage après
l'infiltration d'un rang son logiciel
dans leur système informatique un
logiciel malveillant qui bloquent
l'accès aux données les pirates menacent
ensuite de diffuser les informations
exfiltrées et exige une somme d'argent
pour les restaurer
comme le recommandent les autorités la
stm a refusé de payer la rançon de près
de 3 millions de dollars un crypto
monnaie mais radio-canada a appris que
l'incident d'octobre a mené à une
réclamation à son assureur de 5 millions
$ pour les frais des expertises ailleurs
consacré par ses employés à la gestion
de la crise
la société a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue
jugeant le sujet encore trop sensible la
solution la plus complexe
leur système est des organisations à
protéger leur environnement numérique
externe des cybercriminels mais les
rançons j ciel vont bien souvent
s'introduire subtilement à la suite de
l'ouverture par un employé d'un fichier
joint un courriel c'est le bon levier
qui est descendue de la forteresse
personnes note le bureau d'assurance du
canada perçoit bien l'ampleur du
phénomène notamment en raison de
l'implantation massive du télétravail il
rapporte qu'en 2020 les assureurs ont dû
débourser près de 4 dollars en
indemnisations pour chaque dollar de
primes perçues pour la couverture cyber
responsabilité les primes en cyber
assurances augmenterait actuellement de
10 à 20 % dans certains dossiers de haut
niveau des compétences ou la marche
inévitablement les promotions dans le
stockage de montréal est en effet
victime d'une attaque rançon pendant ce
temps des moyens sont mises en place au
québec pour se défendre contre ces
attaques avec des jeunes pouces offrant
le statu quo peut plus durer
puis cassé le tas de justement de se
tourner vers les technologies émergentes
mento le propose une solution basée sur
la technologie utilisée par les crypto
monnaie la chaîne de blocs afin de
protéger les données
c'est à dire de les passer dans le
déchiqueteur puis de les stocker à des
endroits de stockage diffère donc
advenir qu'un pirate vient mettre
raciale sur un endroit de stockage c'est
pas grave parce qu'on regarde
reconstruire la donner avec seulement
les blocs disponibles
au groupe réa qui offre une technologie
bouclier à de grandes organisations
son président estime qu'il est temps de
mettre à profit les capacités du québec
en cybersécurité ça l'apport du
gouvernement
il est difficile au niveau des plus tôt
de cette entreprise de bien se préparer
mais comme avec une police d'assurance
il est toujours plus difficile
d'investir dans ce qu'on ne voit pas
jusqu'à ce que le malheur frappe ici
mathieu guillon radio canada montréal